there was a woman this story went viral
a woman
my husband found this one actually he
was like i think he would like this
story and i did my ears perked up i was
on fire last night a little bit he's
like i didn't think you were gonna like
it that much i do
there's a woman who has tried to find
her cheating boyfriend she claimed that
he was cheating of course i can't verify
that on tinder
her name is monica
okay this is from newsweek
i'm going to read a little a screenshot
of monica's profile was shared in
reddit's tinder forum over the weekend
by an anonymous poster
okay
if you go to the screenshot of her
let me see if i have the
do i have the screenshot do you have the
screen i didn't print here oh there you
go
monica and she says ah funny story my
man is just swiping he on here and
nothing more oh he's just swiping i
guess that's what he told her i'm just
swiping thought i'd hop on and just
swipe like he is it takes two to tango
babe call me when you see this
okay so apparently her boyfriend
i guess she caught him caught you know
it everyone out there is like there's
been a moment of being caught or
catching somebody right
i've never been caught not a cheater
we'll get to that
um
i guess he said i was just swiping oh
were you really why would you be swiping
it's like i was just walking through the
grocery store just browsing no you don't
go on tinder just to hang out stop it
and
i guess she found out and she decided oh
i'm just gonna do this too i'm gonna
play this game i'm gonna go on there i'm
gonna do what he's doing
okay
so here's the thing
i don't know if he's cheating like i
said i don't know what's going on here
but here's the thing monica if you think
your man is cheating
leave him
don't do this
you think he's cheating what you do is
you say to him hey i see that you're on
tinder what are you doing on twitter you
don't get an answer you're like you're
like you know what that answer doesn't
work for me
so i'm just going to spend the day my
doing my own thing you can go do your
thing i'm going to think about all this
have a nice day shut your phone off go
live your life he will sweat
beads of perspiration like i always say
they will just
tyler knows tyler's in the corner he's
like she's giving some good advice
by going on here and doing this
all you told me is that you're not gonna
break up with this guy you're not
you're seeking attention from him you
want him to see it
it's fun and games to you
you're playing the game but when he
comes crawling back and says oh i was
just swiping like i was just walking
through the grocery store you are going
to accept that you're going to forgive
him and you're going to let him back in
guaranteed
and guess what's going to happen if you
do that and if you treat it this way
he's going to do it again
and then he's going to do it again and
he's going to do it again and he's going
to do it again so stop complaining if
you don't take it seriously so
here's the thing the way you get a man
to stop doing that stuff is you don't
tolerate it now she may decide someone
may decide i'm not saying that you can't
reconcile
i don't know how you feel about cheating
for some people it's like once over for
other people they're like i'll you know
i'll let it go once and then if you
choose to forgive and forget that's up
to you that's totally up to you your
relationship not my decision to make
but i can tell you if you choose to
forgive and forget and you say you
better lay down the law and say if this
happens again and be believable this
happens again you are out
you are out
men are like puppies in many ways
i'm not trying to say men are dogs i
love men this is not supposed to be
degrading to men but listen and women
can be too i guess
you know how when you have a puppy and
you're like you've got a treat
and you're like you're not gonna get
another treat but they know you're gonna
give it to them they know it they know
it they sit there they just wait and
then you're like okay and you give them
another one and another one okay men are
like puppies
they're laughing the men in here are
like oh yeah they know it they know
what's up
so
you need to you need that puppy to know
when i say you're not getting another
treat you're not getting when i say if
this happens again
i'm done i'll have somebody else by noon
mean it
mean it
and there's a big problem going on in
society today because there's a lot
going on we're going to get into with
sex and how women treat sex and how
that's a big problem you need to this is
your temple if you like the short clip
you can catch another one here or you
can catch the full episode right here
[Music]